OUTFRONT tonight, we begin
with the breaking news.
United Airlines revealing
that inspectors have found
loose bolts on more plane door plugs.
As a really sobering right
just to hear that.
It comes just days
after the terrifying incident
that you're looking at here
on that Alaska Airlines flight.
The door
plug blown out of a Boeing 737
that took off
from Portland, Oregon,
with 177 people on board,
left that gaping hole in the plane.
They were flying right
in that moment that you're looking at
at an altitude of 16,000 feet.
A new statement
from United tonight says,
We have found instances that appear
to relate
to installation issues in the door
plug, for example, bolts
that needed additional tightening.
Now, let's just show you
some images of the door plug itself.
That was what was ripped
from the plane on Friday night.
You can see the size there.
It's about the size of a refrigerator.
The NTSB
now saying the plane
was actually restricted
from flying long routes
over the ocean at the time this happened.
Obviously didn't happen over the ocean,
but it had been restricted
from those sorts of flights
because of a warning light
for pressurization
had come on three times in recent weeks,
which had led them to think, well,
then you can't fly it over water
in case you need to land quickly.
Well,
thank goodness for that,
that they were following that
because they did land quickly
and everyone it was alive.
Additional maintenance
was requested, but it was not completed
before Friday's incident.
Now, Boeing shares plummeted today.
Nearly $13
billion were wiped out
from Boeing shares today.
I mean, this is hugely significant.
Boeing, right.
A stalwart of the Dow Jones
Industrial Average,
a black eye for Boeing,
does impact all of America.
It is the largest exporter
for the entire United States.
It is the largest commercial aircraft
manufacturer in the world.
It is a brand.
And its airplanes
stand for American greatness
around the world.
And now you have this on
top of other disasters,
you know, of course,
involving those bestselling
Max planes in recent years,
including two terrible
ones, the fatal crashes in 2018 and 2019.
This now raises major questions
about the company,
its rigor,
which leads us to this Bloomberg
headline that we saw today.
China's Boeing alternative
starts to look enticing.
Not a headline that Boeing ever expected
or wanted to see.
Mike Valerio is OUTFRONT
live from Portland to begin our coverage.
And, Mike,
I mean, a terrifying discovery, right?
Another airline, right,
that had taken the planes out of service
after this incident, sort of
out of an abundance of caution.
And you often expect in these situations,
take it out of service.
Others, no problem.
I was just too cautious.
Now they're finding loose bolts on
multiple door plugs.
What more do you know?
Well, we know.
Thanks for the reporting from our great
and esteemed colleague,
Pete Montini,
Erin, that
in order to have these findings
that United is removing
two rows of seats from its aircraft,
removing airline panels,
panels from the interior of the aircraft
and employing five technicians at a time.
And they found loose bolts
around the door plugs of these aircrafts.
Now, these are ongoing activities
and questions
that are being asked
from hangars across America
to neighborhoods like here in Portland.
We're about 20 minutes
outside of the neighborhood.
And why we're here,
Erin, just imagine Friday
night from 16,000 feet,
a door plug from the Alaska Airlines
plane comes
crashing down into that backyard
just over my left hand shoulder.
That is where Bob's Our Lives
is giving an impromptu news conference
of sorts.
A local science teacher is talking
about the principles of physics
behind the impulse in the freefall
of this piece of the airliner.
But he just wants to know,
like all of us across the country,
how this could happen.
Critical inspections
underway after
a meteor scare at 16,000 feet.
What would you do when you get
when a piece of the plane, a door plug
blew out on Alaska Airlines
Flight 1282,
carrying 177 people on board.
United Airlines
saying it found loose bolts around
the door, plugged on
an undisclosed number of its Boeing
737 max nine aircraft.
171 of those Boeing models
have been grounded with the FAA
announcing, quote, enhanced inspections
after what the NTSB chair calls
an explosive decompression
during Friday's flight.
Passengers
reliving the harrowing moments.
You heard a big loud bang.
To the left, we were
we were like in row 20
and washing sound
and all the oxygen masks
deployed instantly.
And everybody got those on.
A Portland schoolteacher
finding the door
plug of the Alaska Airlines
flight in his backyard.
A crucial piece of evidence
for investigators
getting the door and the other pieces
they will
hopefully be able to pinpoint
exactly where the failure point was.
Remains to be seen
if all the fasteners, bolts or
latches are still on that piece.
The plane's mechanical history
also under scrutiny
prior to Friday's accident.
Alaska Airlines
restricted the aircraft
from flying over the ocean to Hawaii
so it could quickly return to an airport
in case of any warnings.
This after the aircraft's
auto pressurization fail.
Light came on three times
in the past month.
The NTSB says it's unclear
if there's any connection
between those warning lights
and Friday's scare.
So that is what we are looking at
with Alaska right now
and with Boeing right now.
That alert
that illuminated
those three times certainly
is very disconcerting
to our investigators
and we want to look at that.
Found a phone
belonging to an Alaska Airlines
passenger sitting on the ground.
John Bates
heard the NTSB
calling on the public to help
find the missing part of the plane
and found this iPhone
on the side of the road.
It didn't have a screen lock on it,
so I opened it up
and it was an airplane
mode with a travel confirmation
and baggage claim for Alaska. 1282.
The NTSB says the phone screen intact
and a second iPhone, quote,
most likely fell off the plane.
So, Aaron, this is a terrible accident.
Right?
But the NTSB and observers
throughout the aviation
industry keep coming
back to these tributaries of luck.
Thank God
everybody was still strapped
into their seatbelts.
This was not
a cruising altitude at 30,000 feet.
Nobody was sucked
outside of the aircraft.
Dr. Bob, for excuse me, Bob.
For his part,
the physics teacher is saying,
thank God
nobody in this densely
populated neighborhood was hurt.
People were having dinner.
And he said, Erin,
he will not be flying on any max nines
anytime soon.
All right. Thank you very much, Mike.
I mean, it is incredible
when you think about it. Right.
The door could have hit somebody.
The phones on the ground hit somebody.
By the way, it's incredible
that those screens did not shatter.
So many so many things from micro
to macro to think about here.
Miles O'Brien is with me
now, CNN aviation analyst. And Miles,
when you hear the
statement from United right
and this was not
this was an Alaska plane.
This happened
just now, United takes their maxes out.
We're just going to double check
abundance of caution
and all that business.
So I'll be back tomorrow
being the implication.
And then guess what?
No,
there are loose bolts
on an undisclosed
number of planes inspected.
When you hear that,
does that kind of make you worried or.
No,
it's kind of horrifying, Erin.
I mean, this is
the system is built
to tighten the bolts
and put wires through them
and inspect them and sign off on them
and then seal things up and ship
the aircraft.
Something went very wrong along the way
here, apparently.
And when you look at that door
and you look at the hole
in that aircraft,
it does
look as if it was just kind of removed.
There's no real sense of metal tearing.
It's such a clean break
that my initial reaction was
somebody didn't tighten the bolts
and that's what it looks like.
Okay.
So the NTSB has
released a diagram of the door
and you've actually looked into
this in detail. So this door,
you say, is is really
secured by just the four bolts
that are circled on the screen here
just by those four balls.
Now, that in and of itself, while
I guess
maybe that is part of the problem,
but it didn't
necessarily need to be right.
I mean, if they were
if they were tightened correctly,
what could have gone wrong with either
the actual installation
or perhaps with the design?
I don't see you know, I'm
not an engineer.
Let me get this straight here.
But I don't see a problem
with the design.
Assuming the bolts are tightened properly
and the wire is put through them,
which keeps them from,
you know, loosening and,
you know, bolts on aircraft.
Almost all of them have wires or pins
right through them so they don't loosen.
And if that occurred, it
that plugs should have still been there.
Now, it
doesn't sound like a lot
for little bolts,
but in this case, with that design,
it probably should be okay
to handle the load in this case.
But, you know,
this takes me back to that light.
We keep talking about
the pressurization light.
Yeah.
Was that door suddenly leaking?
Perhaps. Maybe.
And we just don't and we just don't know.
And I guess that's the
is the other question
then, is all these other planes out there
that have the same issue,
we don't know now
whether any of them had
the lights go off before.
There's a lot more to find out here.
All right. Thank you very much.
Miles O'Brien.